[Music]
we are putting extra resources into
recruiting elite educators able to
provide interim private tutoring as
demand is high this is driving up tutor
salaries and tuition prices members who
are traveling commercially choosing to
book elite services at airports not your
typical first-class lounge for example
private terminals check-in customs and
security members can request for the
Jetta to be cleared so they minimize the
interactions with other passengers on
their way to their seat
[Music]
because self-isolation tends to be very
effective in containing the virus I
think the super-rich will be less
effective than the rest of us simply
because they have the means to isolate
in much more drastic and much more
large-scale ways the United States
charges people thousands of dollars for
coronavirus tests and truly doesn't have
enough tests to go around but some
reason they have tests available for the
richest people and at the same time as
so many people are worried about whether
or not they're gonna have to miss work
miss a paycheck what they're gonna do
without childcare because so many
schools are closing all these problems
meanwhile you have people spending
millions of dollars to go abroad to go
to private islands to go to private
doctors things that the vast majority
people cannot afford and I do think it
will continue the polarized society
because this is a vast inequality and
inequality that hasn't been seen in
human history
and it's just continuing to get worse
you